hello welcome to this video and then
oops FM card start it's no name right ok
c 1 out of 6 d 4 it's not very common
good squad eight wins four losses
against him okay so one of my name is or
pet lines it was very sharp very sharp
line and well I completely forgot
everything here and 97 I guess when
enter c5 quickly decided to take ya
black ass I'm very quickly with c5 so
I'm going to play that right away and
now yeah this is a very risky line for
wide let me think about it it's that 96
ah yeah 96 looks normal so I'm not going
to remember my analysis now in this
blitz game I only remember that it is
not very good for wide very risky
business but I I don't remember the
precise lines cakes and f6 i guess but
we'll see we'll see yeah white has not
cancelled this is is this important so
f6 now on my head looks like a very
logical move I mean I'm d65 hangs with
check but it still should be right pry
open this position he cannot cancel
because of 94 Bishop c5 losing the Queen
maybe you can do something very greedy
55 and then we should have seven or so
yeah we'll see
hmm I didn't know there were a couple of
interesting alternative
we should have seven and that might be
something came if that is good yeah then
something I mean then chess is a very
weird game Queen B 6 okay i have twin b6
they cannot castle and this is also
efile is wide open
what is this two points right basically
nothing
yeah that that's very time to play so he
can again you cannot castle if i take
FTC 5 is going to play f5 I guess that's
probably the idea yo that's the idea
change mmm that's not so great
queen bee six is not yet working
haha yeah there are a couple of ways to
get good compensation but I'm not quite
sure what the best is this is the issue
it's not so not difficult to find
something decent but what is best okay
I'm playing one of those moves
no tags Bishop takes castles um check on
b6 bishop c6 that's great compensation I
just wasn't sure that's really the best
move or have something else's is better
and it's hard to believe that you cannot
take on the seven
e sassy does need to take okay every 5
f-5 and strictly to move the noid I can
go Quincy for so that's a very pretty
weird-looking move and I don't know just
take the noid
the ship a six yeah let's stop his
castles whose castling rights for for
good
and if it took only five because f5
closes closes some stuff down and I
don't want that so just something like
this maybe
yeah I mean how does he keep all this
stuff together him I don't see it efore
Hanks b3 hangs we should be seven as a
threat okay so yeah I think maybe take
opening up the e-file so you have Queen
h5 some nonsense like that maybe when I
should have done something about that
really should have done something about
it I can give this check though cheyenne
let's do the chick
Quincy three check check so time where
is that mate or do I have to do I have
to check the rook don't see a mate at
the moment even though it feels like
there should be one check there's no
major don't give me that the Rukia hangs
ah come on this is nonsense why is this
working come on check check check I
don't believe this crap it was certainly
some kind of media oops check check
check I made it no I'm not made to check
check check check check mate no I made a
muted I don't believe this oh my god he
so I got a bottom sibley Queen did how
did that happen check i pinned this one
but it's going to meet there ya know or
the big point is that there was a
completely winning position here that I
didn't finish off which is kind of
embarrassing ah yeah okay takes here he
takes f4 is just minus a million
probably now 11 but this should win as
well I mean this is a this is just not
chani going to work yeah my problem was
I thought that I can just take the rook
which I cannot and this irritated me
quite a bit and then I took it still
should win check and now Bishop t6 is
winning yeah that was just entirely
irritating I thought that it should be
didn't didn't see that coming here and
chani so Bishop d 6 wins I was just
irritated that it's not shake made
immediately because I thought it is but
this is of this is winning right it must
be
yes I mean that it's it's simply not
going to work and what this now I know
I'm taking this stuff this is the
problem and the little one I'm playing
so badly sometimes in those positions
that sits it's simply a total shame that
people can get away with this kind of
this kind of crap not developing stuff
taking everything and so on this is just
a real shame and yeah this is also
immediate resignation ruby three you
just completely violated all kinds of
principles just taking material not
developing no king safety and so on this
whole line is basically rubbish for
white okay i have this is this is
probably what my mindset about this and
blegh wins yeah okay but what I did
wasn't bad yeah this is winning is
strong but close to winning you cannot
move the night not you to Bishop g4
anyway this is also pretty dangerous
here this and after that better really
this is just just terribly bad for wider
group III is the most powerful move but
this is also winning minus four is good
enough yeah and this is so I'm not
exactly difficult I don't know
yah yah yah yah okay Jan ok this is also
just made according to the comp which is
not very surprising really and check and
check this a force made it sometimes an
art form yeah to not win and this is
what's one of them and to fire moves
there and said that somehow don't don't
win you can check yeah whatever thanks
for watching